women don't have rights over their
bodies they're making the idea of a nude
Foreman being a shameful thing the tape
that came out recently of Donald Trump
talking about grabbing women by the
[ __ ] it's normalized for us to be told
our bodies are the objects for men and
we don't have legal control over what we
want to do with them I started painting
because I went through quite a bit of
trauma and my childhood and arts to
spend the thing that has been a huge
part of my life ever since it's the way
that other people are able to say things
and talk about what they don't have
words for I was approached by a DejaVu
it's a strip club that's down across the
street from Pike Place Market in Seattle
to paint something on the outside of
their wall that was about sexuality from
a woman's perspective that was a little
bit different than we are usually used
to seeing I wanted to do a pose that
would embrace my sexuality and my
femininity is very excited to be able to
see different representations of what
bodies can look like what women can be
and what sexuality can be I had designed
it finished it but in the process of
painting it DejaVu found an ordinance
from the city
[Music]
I was super emotional I was crying the
whole time I was so happy with how it
turned out Oh was the worst I want
people know how hard that is how awful
that is to like cover up something
that's so important to you
Krystle called me and told me that she
was painting bras on all of the females
in the mural and I was completely
shocked the fact that there's one male
nipple and everything else is covered in
shame is really upsetting this is
actually my first time coming down and
actually seeing the mural in person it's
a really beautiful piece and but I
noticed that there's bras and things
that sort of seemed unnatural to it I
was proud that I was asked to be a part
of the project and when I walked by one
day and saw that a bra had been painted
over it I was offended by that there
were probably a sensor because the men's
get aroused by it grab the right crew
voice at the same time it's like you
know we have to away by the law that's
written it's saying that oh if there's
naked breasts attached to the strip club
it must automatically be to further that
business and further sexual titillation
and we can't have that on the street the
hypocrisy is insane we have a building
here that has women who are in control
of their bodies but yet we have a law
that says that because this building is
here you can't have an image that shows
nudity by covering it up they're making
the idea of a nude woman being a
shameful thing down at the sculpture
garden just a few blocks west of here at
the only fact sculpture garden there's a
statue of a father and a son and they're
both nude we don't censor children in
art because a pedophile might view a
child and be triggered
you don't usually see women in a strong
powerful way and it's important to that
narrative to have it on the outside of a
strip club
this May I was about to board a flight
and I was told that my shorts were too
short and I would have to cover up an
order to get on the plane I felt really
awful I felt angry and a little
embarrassed I breastfed for three years
it was a very challenging psychological
situation because I was fighting my own
internalized shame of my own body
you know someone would give me a nasty
look but there are countless stories of
women being asked to cover up being told
to leave airplanes and so they isolate
themselves and that can lead to
postpartum depression it's normalized
for us to be told that our bodies are
the objects for men and we don't have
legal control over what we want to do
with them yeah I'm looking for me to
talk to about the city ordinance I have
called a bunch of different departments
the people that I've talked to have been
very helpful in trying to get me the
information that I need but nobody seems
to quite know who is the one in charge
as I was painting over it everything
that meant something to me about the
strength of women and everything I've
fought for my whole life to be able to
be a strong woman felt like I was
covering up and it was an issue just of
covering up putting breasts on a mural
but of covering up who I was as as a
strong woman
you
[Music]